انطلاقا من الفهم بان لا قدره تقريبا
لاسرائيل على مواجهه العمليات الفرديه غير
المنظمه ولا عنواننا للرد عليها حاول
نتنياهو عندما تلا اهم قرارات الحكومه
الامنيه المصغره ان يطفي بعدا دراماتيكيا
على القرارات لاحتواء غضب الشارع اليمني
ربما
من يحاول المسافه بين سنستهدفه ونستهدف كل
من يساعده لقد اجرينا اعتقالات في صفوف
دعميه الارهاب والمحرضين وننشر ونعزز
القوه على الجبهات المختلفه
تسهيل ترخيص حمل السلاح للاسرائيليين وسد
او هدموا منازل عائلات منفذ العمليات
ومحاوله تشريع قانون يتيح ابعاد عائلات
المنفذين من القدس والداخل الى جانب تعزيز
الاجراءات الامنيه كانت ابرز ما توافقت
عليه الحكومه الامنيه
بشكل كبير لذلك يتوقع ان يكون خطوات
تصعيديه عقوبات جماعيه وهذا سيغذي يعني
حاله احتقان موجوده والعمليات ربما نحن
امام موجه قد تمتد واذا امتدت ربما يعني
تكود الى وضع همم تفلت فيه الامور وتفقد
فيه السيطره بشكل كامل في اسرائيل ليقرون
بان العمليات الفرديه كالتي جرت في
مستوطنه في القدس الشرقيه المحتله وقتل
فيها سبعه مستوطنين او تلك التي نفذها فتن
في سلوان ضد مستوطنين الى جانب عمليات
اطلاق النار في الضفه
استمر في اطار التصعيد القائم والمتفائم
وفيما حاولت الحكومه استغلالها للتركيز
على الملف الامني وحرف الانظار عن الازمه
الداخليه بسبب الحرب على النظام القضائي
اصر عشرات الالاف من الاسرائيليين على
التظاهر في تل ابيب حيث اجبر الحكومه على
تغيير موقع الاجتماع وفي مدن اخرى ايضا
زياد حلب العربيه القدس الغربيه